did you know that there are unbelievable
research papers on How to simulate the
life of virtual trees we can write a
computer program to simulate how they
move by interacting with them with a
mouse if we go too hard we can simulate
how they break and if we feel like it we
can even burn a tree down or simulate
not one Burning Tree but even an entire
Forest dear fellow Scholars this is to
many papers with Dr car now for a more
peaceful simulation we can simulate the
life of complete ecosystems for a
thousand years as well this is a story
of human Ingenuity yes all of these were
handcrafted techniques no AI of any sort
was used to make this and I have good
news for you fellow Scholars we even
have more papers in this area and I have
found some new ones that are beyond
amazing for instance the previous works
showed what happens above the ground but
a great deal of a tree's life also
happens underground as this popular tree
develops over time so do its roots as
well now take a careful look at the
shape of the roots and now have a look
at this pine tree
growing wow the popler went vertical the
pine went horizontal
now why does this happen well popular
trees are rapid growing but relatively
shortlived trees and they primarily grow
in areas where water is deeper down in
the soil and with these roots they can
reach them now the pine tree sees the
world entirely differently its roots are
horizontal thus maximizing water and
nutrient absorption near the surface as
an additional bonus it gets stabilized
in unfriendly environments where the
soil is loser very smart now what about
the oak the oak is a wise tree and what
does a wise tree do of course it
diversifies its bets its deep tap rooot
system gives it access to deep water
sources but it also has widespread
horizontal roots for maximum nutrient
absorption thus giving it great
longevity great choice H I feel a bit
like David atoro here however the story
does not end here a good tree root
simulation has to take into
consideration how smart and adaptable
these little plants are you see
environmental stimulus matters a great
deal in their development for instance
when growing around the slope of a hill
it will need a different kind of root
system to survive
loving it so is that it is that all this
simulator can take into consideration
well not quite now hold on to your
papers and look at this fellow Scholars
holy mother of papers it simulates the
effect of all of these parameters and
this is not even a complete list for
instance it simulates how different
kinds of soils exist and show a
different growth resistance factor and
we can also mix them up so it can
simulate heterogenous systems what does
that mean well multiple soil types
scattered across this virtual world
absolutely beautiful and the tree will
grow as a tree should grow in reality
hopefully and as we change the
distribution of soil types so does this
wise little tree adapt to its
environment it even learns to avoid
regions of high growth resistance and it
grows around it thus simulating
asymmetric growth so good and now I
wonder how much computation does such a
simulation take I mean we need to
simulate these virtual trees for years
and years so does it take years and
years of computation time in real life
look at that not at all fellow Scholars
we can simulate some such a system on
the scale of months in a matter of
seconds simulating 60,000 little roots
in less than 3 seconds and sometimes
even
interactively wow now at this point I
have one more question left you know
what it is are these simulations for
show or is this how reality works well
let's see about that when compared to a
previous paper that digitizes tree root
system systems in real life this is the
real deal now does the simulator live up
to these results look at that my
goodness Clean Sweep loving it not only
the kinds of structures are very similar
but I actually have to look real close
to find the differences it needn't be
perfect and yet it almost is wow and it
gets better the root and shoot ratios
for real trees are not known and the
simulated Oaks properties are very
similar to the ones seen in real trees
and now imagine that the games and
virtual worlds of the future could be
with simulations that are this realistic
we could play in these world in the
future what a time to be alive and once
again all this was done through sheer
human Ingenuity no AI technique was used
in this paper and the paper contains so
much more analysis you simply have to
take a look a beautiful piece of work of
course it is because this is a sigraph
paper what is that sigraph is the most
sacred place for some of the best
computer Graphics papers ever getting a
paper accepted there is in my opinion
like winning the Olympic gold medal of
Graphics research huge congratulations
however computer Graphics is a field
that is orders of magnitude smaller than
AI research for instance look at this
goodness this paper was seen by about
200 fellow Scholars and I fear that if
we don't talk about works like this here
on two minute papers almost no one will
here I try to be a good ambassador of
computer Graphics research and show
everyone how amazing these papers are
and can give to the world so much and it
breaks my my heart that so few people
know about them but good news I have
more papers like this up the sleeve if
you wish to not miss out on them when
they come in the future make sure to
subscribe and hit the Bell icon
experiment tracking model evaluation and
production monitoring for your deep
learning projects and llm apps this is
what weights and biases does and it is
the best everyone is using it try it out
now at wnb domme slapers or click the
link in the description below